this is the reject way
we back in business
oh just finished re-watching season one
that's why we're late
you must reunite
is
yeah what's your name the wrestler sasha
banks
this is
just to hear those words oh
snap
[Applause]
hey
oh damn
oh [ __ ] this is the way baby
happy halloween
[Music]
it's a treat for you man
this show can so get away with showing a
trailer
that doesn't show much just a few weeks
before it comes out
all you need is that answer this show
all right guys we're going to do
658 things you've missed in the
mandalorian season 2 trailer right now
all right yeah that was a great teaser
fantastic teaser let me tell you guys
about my morning
[Laughter]
i woke up at seven because i heard that
there might be a mandalorian trailer
and i was like all right nothing came
out they usually drop their stuff
between 6 30 to 7. i went back to bed
woke up at 8 30
and then i was like aw crap a
mandalorian trailer came
out minutes after i woke up
oh call john get your ass over here damn
it
this is the way this is get over here
damn it
i feel like there's so many things you
can meme out of this trailer especially
uh with the with the egg baby
yeah that is gonna be all over i'm sure
it's not already all over
twitter oh must be all over twitter by
this point yeah by the hour we're
getting this up
yeah five minutes later
you know how it goes yeah yeah yeah for
sure but i did love this trailer
it was a solid tease in the sense that
they're
they're overlapping the footage over the
armors dialogue
from the end of season one i believe
that hooded figure and i
when i say i believe i know because i
googled sasha banks before this jump cut
yeah i was like that's definitely sasha
banks there because you know that that's
what's like you see her like is that a
superstar
but then i got a better look at her face
i was like oh wait i i heard about sasha
banks being cast
i think it was just a rumor for a little
bit but uh
yeah then i saw her like that's
definitely her i heard when she was cast
she was supposed to be like an
ally in some way it could be the kind of
thing where it starts off where
maybe she seems villainous at first but
then eventually
morphs into ally uh down the season
or maybe she's estranged from some other
group and needs help from you know a
drifter like mando
i'm not sure i fee i feel like based off
what john favreau was talking about in
that
entertainment weekly article it's gonna
feel more
serialized than the last season like
last season was serialized but the
episodes felt a little bit more isolated
and then they started like really tying
in eventually
kind of feel like the a western show and
then oh this it becomes a very
serialized show by the end right
and i think this one is going to be much
more
unified from the get-go that's the
impression i'm getting because the tail
seems a lot more
immediate you know he has this child he
wants to take the child
to find out its origins they're also
fugitives i mean you see here that you
got the republic who seems to be hunting
them down as well
we want to clone yoda too you know well
i mean it makes me wonder because
he is in a unique position because of
course i mean the empire would want to
you know experiment on destroy
whatever the child but you know yeah the
rebels have had experience with actual
yoda so
maybe if they found out they would want
yeah to
i don't know take the kid and maybe they
think they know what's best to do with
them or something but yeah i mean
it is definitely a cool signifier of
conflicts to come because that's also
going to
potentially pit us against the people
we've been rooting for for most of what
has attached everybody to star wars
yeah so you know that could be a cool
just yeah way to create
anti-heroism you know within the world
of mando yeah it was a great tease i
mean
it felt really grounded for you
you have some like great sweet sweet
shots in here
at the same time though it's like just
you know tone mood
atmosphere a little bit of battle but
then they even have like the fight at
the end or they just cut to black and
they don't even ruin the fight for you
all knocked out at the end yeah i think
this is just a great example of a really
well thought out teaser because all it
does is it hints at
it shows you some cool moments and stuff
yes but it also
i think subtly hints that yeah we're
going to expand into more worlds we have
you know what looks like
um uh you know you had the snow you know
what at least conjured up hoth in my
mind you had that like port looking town
by the
the sea yeah things like that so you all
and then you have this like yeah big
boxing ring which you reminded me of
that first teaser in the sense that he's
in the bar and he does the thing with
the big closing door
um but this yeah i'd love that they just
cut to black because we already know
it's like if you're sitting here
watching this trailer you are gonna be
imagining in your head all the cool
things mandalore is probably doing
as he's doing that and they gave us
shots of everything
we wanted ahsoka tana boca tan moff
gideon with the dark saber that's
right everything that we've been hoping
to see more
episode of the clone wars into this
trailer
just just for the fans man just sabine
red oh my god she's in the show
i actually think boba fett i actually
think it's great that they didn't even
show that
or unless some youtuber you know like
screen crush or new rockstars comes out
with a video later today
you're like even look here that's
clearly boba fett yeah
his head is poking out from behind a box
yeah i'm not gonna
hunt that down in terms of what they
made front and center they didn't even
show much of that and i think that's
really really awesome that they're
keeping as much of this
mystery as possible especially because i
heard the secrecy was already you know
pretty strict on season one
i can only imagine how strict the
secrecy was
for season two and they're already
gearing up to shoot season three right
now
i'm very excited to watch this
relationship develop
to see you know and yeah do i want to
see all the other characters absolutely
but keeping it
focused on its t's with just mando and
child
amanda and child a couple familiar faces
i mean you see like cara dune again and
you see carl weathers again but i like
that they're leaving and he plays carl
weathers this season
i remember his character name that's
funny i don't know why
i don't know why i remember cara dude
any other bit part from season one three
grief cargo
grief card cargo yeah yeah not cargo
i don't know cara dune carl weathers
cargo carano
all right guys so what did you think
about this mandalorian trailer do you
excite you it should if you're watching
it and she just came here
to hate it you could look like or just
hear about it but without actually
seeing it which you know fair enough
fair game i suppose hey you know you can
do you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell
we also did do reactions for all of the
mandalorian season one here on youtube
so you can check out that playlist
with a card up above youtube things
and uh last but not least
this one's easy it's like who am i gonna
shout out
who if they were in danger no matter
what
would i protect as if they are my own
child
that's easy you guys ready for him his
name's
tyler hague undoubtably
tyler hague is the one i would protect
and he's the one who would need it the
most
i'm so happy i'm imagining this sure is
he a little bigger than me
is he stronger than me is he taller than
me
could he easily just hold me down and
choke me to death
yes like a baby yoda would i've imagined
it
so tyler hague i'm telling you buddy
wherever you go if you ever i was gonna
try to
quote ain't no matter high enough and i
totally forgot all the lyrics i'm sorry
okay wherever you go tyler if you ever
need someone to take you across the
galaxy
to show you to some cantina full of scum
and villainy
to get some paid ladies you know what i
mean
i don't want to say the word because of
disney plus keywords i can get this
demonetized
well you know well while you're busy
doing that he can go get himself a
tattooing
or something i like when you have a word
i like when you help
yes here to sprinkle the spice on
which is a different sci-fi sorry tyler
we done this is the way
[Music]
you